je n'y suis encore ayant gagné
suisse en commun
m
[Musique]
mad max
encore
non
mais
niveau
ado
m
oui
[Musique]
et pour nous
lundi politique
gaël le dantec lors de son élection
comme député la réunion en juin dernier
elle avait d'abord remercier dieu quand
on lui demande de quel bord politique
elle elle répond qu'elle est du parti de
la population
médecin à sainte suzanne elle devient
conseillère générale en 1995 après
plusieurs échecs politiques elle rallie
didier robert entre les deux tours de
l'élection régionale de 2010 et devient
vice-présidente de la région puis
retrouver un siège au département dans
son quartier natal du chaudron où elle a
gardé quelques appuis quelques biens
elle devient également au vice
présidente du conseil départemental
avant de battre à l'ex socialiste
monique orphé dans la sixième
circonscription il ya presque un an
ovni politique et le siège avec les
républicains à l'assemblée et pose
fièrement avec les maquereaux lors d'un
voyage officiel en inde
elle revendique un penchant pour les
questions sociales mais c'est toujours
alliée avec la droite réunionnaise
on essaiera aujourd'hui d'en savoir un
peu plus sur les convictions de notre
invité est sur son action politique
nadia ramassamy député la réunion
conseillère régionale est l'invité de
lundi politique sur la première et vous
pouvez nous suivre qui nous écouter la
radio vous pouvez également me suivent
en vidéo sur le site internet de la
première nadia ramassamy pour soi merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
voudrait qu'on démarre peut-être pas un
sujet d'actualité récente vous êtes et
sa complète le portrait que j'ai fait en
introduction présidente de l'intergroupe
parlementaire de l'outre-mer à paris à
ce titre vous avez demandé au ministre
de l'intérieur de déclarer l'état de
catastrophe naturelle pour l' union
suite au passage de la tempête fakir
est-ce que c'est aux parlementaires
flamands de faire cette demande ce
serait pas plutôt au maire au préfet
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose que
les parlementaires appuyé cette demande
bien sûr déjà un bon jour à tout la tour
les réunionnaises et les réunionnais qui
nous écoutent ça fait que je suis
président de l'intergroupe parlementaire
en fait outre mer ça veut dire que il ya
un président autres maires à l'assemblée
nationale un président délégation donc
autres mr au sénat et moi en fait je
suis président de l'intergroupe des deux
donc du parlement fait de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
effectivement bon bain dans ce cadre
autant en tant que député de la réunion
et c'est tout à fait normal que nous
intervenons pour pour demander au
gouvernent
mon d'intervenir pour avoir des moyens
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai que par
notre le fait que le député on est quand
même plus proche du gouvernement
pour être entendu déjà d'ailleurs si on
a voté pour nous c'est pour bien
représenter représenter dignement cette
population et vous savez qu'il est quand
même de grosses catastrophes autant
pendant dans toutes les communes parce
que ça a été hyper hyper rapide un peu
de temps un désastre total comme il ya
des années où il a eu vraiment une
un désastre et comme je donne un exemple
l'agriculture plus de environ on a
estimé environ 8 millions d'euros la
perte en agriculture donc et d'en haut
niveau des maisons des gens au niveau
contenu de pas mal de structure donc
c'est vrai que nous sommes les mieux
mieux représente
on ressent en tout cas mieux le la
population de la réunion
est ce que vous considérez que la
préfecture a correctement géré cette
situation l'association pendant le
passage de de fakir et ajustements il
est question de voir comment faire suite
à tous ces aléas parce que c'est vrai
que au départ on pense toujours que les
comment ça ça va pas être vraiment
quelque chose de très important et c'est
après qu'on se rend compte donc il est
question actuellement dont je veux dire
c'est tout à fait normal et légitime
c'est vrai au départ que le préfet
voyant que ça ne vient pas avec cette
vue ce qu'on lui dit dans la météo c'est
tout à fait normal que des repas non je
pense non il faut revoir le système de
leurre le système dallaire de là il faut
revoir d'ailleurs 20 ministres eux mais
on en a parlé c'est ça qui est très
important au revoir le système dallaire
est ce que on va pas mettre d'autres
indicateurs pour pouvoir mettre plus
rapidement la leyre pour certains
responsables politiques pointent du
doigt une urbanisation qui aurait
peut-être été fait de manière un peu
anarchique et qui aurait provoqué aussi
peut-être plus de d'écoulement des eaux
mal maîtrisé je ne sens car on pense je
ne pense pas parce que les catastrophes
naturelles on peut pas les prévoir déjà
et moi je pense
non c'est parce qu'il ya eu quand même
dans des endroits où il n'y a pas
vraiment d'urbanisation il ya eu quand
même beaucoup de dégâts donc non je ne
pense pas que ça vient de là nadia
ramassamy vous étiez mois dernier au
monde avec emmanuel macron invité donc
par le présent la république à
l'accompagner durant ce voyage officiel
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté qu'est
ce que ça apporte à la réunion à la
réunion ça apporte beaucoup parce que
déjà vous savez que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mon c'est vrai qu'on est dans la zone
océan indien mais pas vraiment reconnu
de façon officielle et grâce au
président macron il a pu rendre
officielle la position stratégique nous
avons nous mais bon les réunionnaises et
réunionnais donc la réunion et c'est
vrai que pour la première fois en fait
il ya eu un accord où la france dont
deux faisant de la république a reconnu
au niveau de langue que c'est un point
stratégique très important donc c'est
vraiment la france dans l'océan indien
est d'ailleurs grâce à cet accord pour
la première fois donc il y aura un
échange de 2,2 tout ce qui est aérien et
maritime
donc on y aura des échanges où les
bateaux indiens ou même les avions
pourront venir à la réunion et on a même
donné là on met aussi à leur disposition
tout ce qui est logistique
quand je veux dire c'est quelque chose
de très important on parle là des choses
commerciaux de tout ça ça pète des
échanges commerciaux des échanges de
vues stratégiques beaucoup c'est à dire
les lutteurs militaire a oui voilà
militaire parce que normalement le
préfet doit après repartir en inde pour
concrétiser tout ça je veux dire que par
exemple le port de la réunion pourrait
accueillir des navires militaires
indiens y compris en cas de crise avec
la chine parce qu'on sait que les
actions sont confiants
de fait exactement donc je vais dire est
ce que c'est une bonne idée de mettre la
réunion s'est déjà c'était une bonne
idée pour moi de mettre en avant la
réunion
avant de penser à des choses négatives
quand je pense qu'il faut d'abord penser
aux choses positives
j'ai d'ailleurs à des échanges beaucoup
plus important entre l'inde et la
réunion et c'est le but recherché
c'est de mettre en avant notre île le
fait de de prioriser donc cet accord ça
nous donne beaucoup plus des changes à
faire et regarder plus loin pour moi le
côté positif de la chose
ça c'est un autre président de l'inca
notre président n'a pas c'est vraiment
le premier président qui a pris en
compte et moi je suis d'ailleurs très
beau parler la bonne addition honoré de
voir que le président on va jouer contre
comme sur ce tir de d'accord stratégique
est-ce que ça mais pas quand même la
réunion en position de cible dans un
éventuel conflit ce que c'est une bonne
idée à tour parce que quand on a fait ça
n'a que cet accord c'était plus pour se
défendre contre tous qui est terrorisme
donc je veux dire c'était ça qui était
le plus important
et là on se trouve quand même bien armé
pour que demain quand tu auras tout ce
qui vient de l'extérieur pour justement
venir détruire la limite je dirais la
réunion bah en fait en ayant cette union
il ya plus une
une solidarité une coordination surtout
contre le terrorisme beaucoup plus il
faut plus regarder dans ce sens et là on
sera vraiment protéger parce qu'on a
quand même lan avant que la france
arrive ya quand même l'un qui est là et
je pense que c'est un pays très
développé et très dans beaucoup d'action
est ce que dans les accords commerciaux
est ce qu'il ya des pistes concrètes
pour un avantage pour la réunion est ce
que dans ces accords qui sont passées
actuellement est ce que la réunion peut
il tirer un avantage concret gers avec à
la réunion il ya quand même plus de 40%
de la population dans ce sont des
dizaines d'indiens en fait qu'ils sont
d'origine de l'inde depuis environ 3 4
générations
donc moi je pense oui bien sûr comme
autant l'un avec maurice et l'inde avec
la réunion c'est très important pour la
rime est ce que les pistes concrètes de
d'euros dans cette séance
en fait en études parce que justement le
préfet devrait partir bientôt pour voir
avec aussi l'ambassadrice ambassadeur de
france donc je veux dire tout ça c'est
un chantier qu'il faut qu'on développe
dans dans nos rapports avec l'un de vous
lier aussi la culture on sent un regain
d'intérêt pour la culture indienne de la
part des descendants d'immigrants
d'engager est-ce qu'il faut encourager
ce retour aux sources y compris
religieux ou est-ce qu'il faut se méfier
d'une forme de communautarisme qui
pourrait se développer
je pense pas c'est ce que vous dites moi
je pense que au contraire
autant on fait avec d'autres pays
je pense que l'inde fait partie des pays
de l'océan indien entend on
on priorise également tournés tous les
autres pays au niveau de l'océan indien
je pense que l'un en fait partie et il
faut plus voir dans ce sens au des
changes entre ces indiens pour avoir
pour faire de l'océan indien une base
très importante et où tous les gens sont
associés pour un intérêt général mais
pas je pense pas que il a fait ça plus
dans un sens pour développer le goût
comment est ce que vous voyez cette ce
rapport la culture indienne ici à la
réunion ou parce qu'ils pensaient qu'il
faut accompagner ce développement il
faut aller plus loin
vous savez que la région a besoin d'être
développés vous avez qu on est quand
même une île où il ya un taux de chômage
très important et ça passe par un
programme culturel autant culturelle
pour les jours en fait c'était plus
culturelle à mon sens vous vous rajoutez
le côté religieux mais moi je pense que
c'était plus le côté culturel autant on
fait aussi avec d'autres d'autres prêts
d'autres pays envoie en développement où
ils représentent quand même des
puissances mondiales
moi je pense que c'est plus dans ce sens
que nous on va avoir des effets positifs
pour la réunion
moi c'est plus en ce sens est d'ailleurs
c'est notre rôle à nous ensuite de voir
par rapport à l'inde nous après au
niveau des reins
on d'avoir plus de contacts des changes
pour pouvoir profiter au maximum et pour
que les retombées soient au niveau de la
réunion ça mais je le disais en
introduction lente de votre élection
comme député vous avez d'abord remercier
dieu est rappelé que vous aviez prier
jésus pendant des heures le jour du vote
est ce que ça pose pas un problème en
fait c'est parce que c'est dans les
caisses que ça parce qu'un problème de
respect de la laïcité et plus et
quelques élus de la république met en
avant sa sa religiosité
moi je suis si on doit revenir sur du je
crois en dieu universel je veux dire que
ce soit dieu catholique que ce soit dieu
au niveau 2 des musulmans que ce ça dieu
au niveau du bouddhisme que ce soit dieu
au niveau des hindous je veux dire que
pour moi c'est dieu universel et ont
regardé monsieur macron il a bien vu des
évêques dont je veux dire que c'est plus
dans un mélange remercier dieu son
élection il y eu sa vie la vie quand
même dit vino il a vu il a vu tous les
représentants des religions différentes
donc pour moi je pense que dieu pour la
plupart des réunionnaises et réunionnais
dieu est quand même important donc pour
moi j'estime que c'est un c'était
c'était ma façon à moi de remercier tous
ces personnes voulaient pas que ça
puisse éventuellement poser en
provenance de l'algérie tout pas du tout
non non pas du tout moi je respecte
d'ailleurs toute personne et j'estime
que là c'était un moyen de remercier les
gens qui m'ont aidé et qui ont sûrement
prier parce qu'ils croient en dieu voilà
vendredi le président emmanuel macron a
confirmé la création d'une fondation
pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé et de son
abolition
est ce qu'il faudrait ici à la réunion
un lieu un monument un moyen de mieux
commémorer cette abolition de l
esclavage ici à rennes on a déjà dans
chaque ville souvent il ya déjà sept
représentations
le jour du 20 décembre mais pourquoi pas
je dire si demain il ya une proposition
faite au niveau de la réunion pourquoi
pas étant donné qu'il a quand même
concrétisé sur le plan national pourquoi
pas l'arena moi je suis partante
quelqu'un me demande bien sûr mais vous
même
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord pour
quelles que soient les pour les
différents détenus moi je pense que
quand ils veulent avoir un symbole d'une
victoire ou d'un grand combat je pense
que c'est tout à fait normal moi je suis
partant pour aider dans toutes ses
toutes ces personnes qui veulent
commémorer faire quelque chose de
grandiose par rapport au combat qu'ils
ont mené bien sûr dans l'actualité il ya
cette mobilisation de tous les élus sur
le dossier des allocations logement pour
la question de la propriété qui a été
supprimée qui laisse sur le carreau
beaucoup de réunionnais qui espérait
acheter une case grâce à cet appel est
l'accession beaucoup d'artisans c'est
qu'ils comptaient sur ces constructions
pour avoir des contrats de commande on
vous dit qu emmanuel macron vous a
rassuré sur ce point oui exactement est
ce que ce sera officiellement un papier
quelque chose qui nous dit bah ça y est
c'est bon c'est sûr il va ça va être
rétablie ou est ce que c'est alors bon
projet non je pense pas parce que quand
on a voyagé donc le vendredi dans toute
la journée noté dans l'avion dont j'ai
déjeuné à sa table et donc je lui ai
parlé je lui ai dit monsieur macron vous
savez que le fait d'arrêter la pl à la
réunion pause ça va pas en tout cas
niveau favoriser nos valises et parce
que pour moi le fait comme j'ai expliqué
je vais expliquer comme ça le fait
au lieu de rendre propriétaire des gens
qui sont dans des logements sociaux
vous allez rendre ces gens tributaire
d'une allocation logement à vie avec une
espérance de vie longue dont je veux
dire vous quelque part vous allez perdre
de l'argent et lui m'a répondu de façon
très sincère c'est ça qui était bien il
m'a dit je n'étais pas au courant et ils
s'adressent après hominis qui étaient
autour et à moi-même et dit je vous
avais dit que au niveau des autres
maires de la réunion il ya quand même
des spécificités qu'il faut qu'on prenne
en compte au delà de deux mondes est
français donc il a dit que suite aux
assises
outre mer il va faire quand même une loi
autres maires où il va réintégrer ses
spécificités qui apporte beaucoup pour
les réunionnaises et réunionnais ensuite
bon quand on arrive en aime toutes et
protocolaire donc je dire là y voit le
premier ministre mme odile le président
de l'unfp donc tout et protocolaire nous
mêmes on voit des députés on voit des
organisations non gouvernementales et
autres et puis quand on reprend l'avion
le lundi j'ai bon il m'a il et revenez
nous voir et parce qu'on est juste avec
les ministres n'ont été alors il je
redis mais monsieur macron est ce que
pour vous à ce que pourra par rapport à
l'appel il m'a dit vous m'avez déjà
parlé de ça vendredi je n'ai pas oublié
donc je vais suite aux assises voir ses
spécificités et faire une autre mère où
on intègre alors j'ai dit mais monsieur
macron est ce que je peux dire aux
réunionnaises et réunionnais quand je
rentre à la réunion oui oui vous pouvez
dire que il y aura ses spécificités on
va les intégrer en fait j'ai pu se
raisonner avec un président qui veut
quand même essayer de trouver des moyens
pour ne pas dépenser de l'argent ne pas
gaspiller parce qu'on doit redresser la
france
donc le fait d'avoir raisonner comme ça
et c'est la vérité d'ailleurs c'est sûr
que ben quand on on avoir le problème
différemment de façon intelligente je
dirais automatiquement ya quand même une
réaction intelligente qui se passe mais
tous les autres députés ont aussi saisi
je vais vous dire il ya deux mois avant
en tant que président de l'egypte hommes
dont un intergroupe parlementaire
outre mer j'ai interpellé la présidente
la ministre d'outre-mer et elle avait ce
jour là elle avait convié le secret te
conseiller outre-mer de l'elysée le
conseiller outre-mer de matignon
monsieur sorin qui était présent notre
ancien préfet qui était directeur de
cabinet et puis ses conseillers à elle
quand je lui en ai parlé elle m'a dit ok
mais on verra ça après et quand j'ai vu
le président deux mois après et j'ai eu
cette chance que j'ai été invité par le
président la république
quand il m'a dit je n'étais pas au
courant ça veut bien dire que quel que
soit nous ce qu'on fait ça n'arrive pas
un travail bah moi je pense que du
moment que ça arrive pas au niveau du
président c'est qu'il ya un problème
soit je pense que les ministres
concernés ne vois pas l'importance du
problème donc en fait ils ont peut-être
d'autres il priorise d'autres problèmes
alors que pour moi savez que quand je
suis allé en inde à g président des
ruines mon premier moi ce que j'ai vu
c'était surtout les réunionnaises et
réunionnais donc j'ai pu par ce petit
passage la proche de lui faire passer ce
message et je vous assure que c'est plus
lui qui décide mais il faut que au moins
il faut que tout n'est que ses ministres
défendent un de nos intérêts peut-être
que c'est peut-être pas le cas
en tout cas il priorise pas de la même
façon que nous en tout cas sur la
question du logement la région c'est un
sujet auquel vous avez toujours dit vous
intéressez vous avez des responsabilités
au conseil départemental notamment en
ahl sentiment que rien ne bouge qui a
toujours autant de gens qui attendent un
logement social toujours autant de cette
entreprise du btp qui se plaignent parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de 2,2 de commandes
qu'est-ce qu'il va pas qu'est ce qui
coince
alors moi je n'en ai déjà je tiens à
dire que c'est vrai que depuis 2010 mois
au niveau de la région
c'est moi qui ai demandé donc vous fait
bien partie de ces politiques
responsables
alors je vous redis juste l'historique
depuis ton temps que la région exister
quand je suis devenue vice-présidente de
la région
j'ai demandé que l'on mette de l'argent
sur le logement social première fois
depuis trente ans donc on a mis 20
millions d'euros pour la construction de
logements neufs
ensuite progressivement vous voyez qu'il
y avait un problème en tout cas depuis
2000 2015 quand je suis redevenu
conseillère générale 2
ou département conseillère
départementale j'ai vu que par manque de
moyens on ne faisait plus d'amélioration
d'habitat pour les familles
réunionnaises on faisait que pour les
personnes âgées personnes handicapées
pour une valeur de 7000 euros
alors qu'avant on faisait beaucoup plus
donc moi je suis intervenu encore en
2015 je suis resté dans la majorité de
la région uniquement pour encore une
fois à représenter ces personnes et j'ai
demandé je reste travailler avec eux à
condition que il met en place
l'amélioration de l'habitat et comme par
la loi notre de 2015 la loi ne nous a
permis d'intervenir sur le logement
donc on a pu mettre des millions d'euros
pour l'amélioration d'habitat alors
pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya toujours ce
problème il faut pas oublier que nous
sommes nous avons quand même une
démographie de plus en plus important
donc autant il y a il ya des choses qui
sont faites autant il ya également des
nouvelles familles est de plus en plus
de personnes savait que nous ça augmente
de plus en plus dont je pense que il ya
ont fait on fait mais ayant encore ce
petit ce décalage et je pense que dans
les mois et années à venir
en tout cas moi je vais plus me battre
dans au niveau national pour que les
choses avancent et autant au niveau
local également vous étiez à propos de
logements jusque récemment présidente de
tact réunion où l'opérateur logement
social ou même a été reconduite à la
présidence
oui pourquoi la presse parle de
l'alliance politicienne bay aurait fait
finalement vous n'avez pas eu non non
pas du tout vous savez que partout où je
vais je laisse des traces
quand je suis devenu vice-président de
l'économie solidaire au département en
98 en 2001 j'ai fait le dispositif à des
aides départementales aux entreprises
nouvelles
aujourd'hui puis sur le pas mais je
continue suite à ça je suis allé à la
région j'ai mis en place le logement
social
ensuite au niveau du département en 2015
j'ai mis en place le tage c'est une led
pour des jeunes pour créer leur propre
activité plus de 500 jeunes travaillent
grâce à ça quand j'étais arrivé au pas
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un problème entre
le département qui fait moins qui
investit moi parce que ils ont fait eux
mêmes une une spl avenir réunion où il
s'améliore de leur côté donc le pack
était voué à 10
donc moi j'ai dit c'est une loi 1901 le
pack
donc moi j'ai encore comme vous avez que
j'ai quand même j'ai ma je représente
quand même une entité politique donc je
suis intervenu au niveau de la région en
disant moi je suis d'accord pour
continuer à travailler mais à condition
qu'on ont sauvé le pas mais surtout oui
mais au maire de lui vous pourquoi ce
que vous avez pas trop en fait ça me
casse que oui mais parce que ce qui se
passe c'est que je suis député j'ai
voulu pour les les employés les
administratifs parce qu'ils ont toujours
peur de quelqu'un qui arrive et qui a
pas la même organisation qui n'a pas le
même mais mental que moi la même action
de trouver des solutions pour que des
gens avancent donc je pense moi c'est
plus dans ce but que je me suis présenté
et j'ai bien dit aux journalistes
d'ailleurs j'ai pas fait de voix j'ai
fait plus de cent voix c'est le
représentant du département qu'elle un
fait deux mois je tiens à préciser que
j'ai dit aux journalistes
ouf je passe jeu sauf et puis je
continue mon travail donc je pense que
pour soi est candidate et vous n'avez
pas déjà fait non mais attendez je les
fais uniquement parce que tout en
sachant que en tant que parce que à un
moment donné ils ont laissé flotter que
un député ne pouvait pas être président
d'une organisation loi 1901 est donc
uniquement dans ce flot jeu mais je vous
redis les administratifs du pat ont été
sauvées y avait trente emplois lors la
question c'était juste ma question c'est
est en cours je pense que moi je suis
très positive si je n'ai pas été
reconduit c'est parce qu'il ya quelque
chose de plus important qui m'attend au
delà et que je serai là bas vous savez
les importance parce que je sais des
choses à faire encore et je vais aller
au delà comme je vous dis sur le plan
national
on doit se battre pour que ça se
répercute comme j'ai déjà fait avec le
président la république il ya bien
d'autres actions qu'on peut faire au
niveau national donc mon travail est
d'aller encore au delà et comme j'ai
déjà laissé quelque chose de très
positif
au suivant de continuer pas si je vous
dis je vais je me suis présentée
uniquement pour aider ces gens qui
voulaient que je reste donc c'est
uniquement par sympathie pour eux que je
les voulais pas les effets bah en fait
du moment
pour moi j'ai pas dit ça du moment que
quelqu'un me remplace quelles que soient
les les
les arrangements comme on a dit c'est
pas ça je suis pas dangereux mais en
fait pour moi n'y a pas d'arrangement
politique de nomination de jours je vous
redis quand on vient pour faire du bien
pour les gérants on le fait un moment
quand il ya quelque chose qui se passe
pour que vous n'êtes plus à ce poste
c'est parce qu'il ya quelque chose de
plus important qui vous attend et c'est
pour ça que je me suis dit moi je suis
hyper positif dans tout ce que je fais
je viens uniquement pour aider les gens
je suis pas venu faire une politique
politicienne je suis venu et des dangers
en difficulté c'est ans que je viens
faire parler à la parole politique
quand même parce que vous êtes élus et
donc vous avez aussi des alliances
politiques pour cela quels sont
aujourd'hui vos rapports avec la droite
réunionnaise est ce que vous êtes plutôt
didier robert plus tôt michel fontaine
qui essaient pour tous pour qu'ils n'ont
rien fait de mal donc je suis pour tout
le monde il faut pas choisir son camp à
un moment bas pour l'instant je choisis
les rhinoise et rené et je sois je
choisi de travailler pour quelle que
soit la voie que je dois prendre
eh bien regardez monsieur macron moi je
suis pau ce qu'il est en train de faire
dans l'intérêt des réunionnaises et
réunionnais donc je dire je savais
quelque chose par rapport aux autres je
vous dis tout de suite par rapport aux
autres élus je me suis fait moi-même
grâce à une population dont je veux dire
si j'avance j'avance en en faisant
avancer derrière moi aussi des gens qui
ont besoin de moi donc j'ai un
raisonnement totalement pas je ne dois
rien à aucun parti politique n'a aucun
élu de la vigne je les ai donc vos amis
sur sa santé vous entendez leader robert
g fonctionner avec didier robert pour
qu'il soit élu c'est différent c'est
différent ça fait combien vous au
premier tour dossier s'effondre et 15
mille voix vous rendez ça représente un
peu plus de 6%
ah mais attendez entre une personne
isolée et deux personnes qui viennent
lorsqu'il faut vraiment souligner c'est
que c'est que la politique pour arriver
à des postes de responsable du théier
l'homo il faut passer aujourd'hui vos
avances à sont plutôt en région plutôt
avec michel fond je suis pour les
alliances qui emmène très loin les
réunionnaises et réunionnais mais dans
le bon sens du terme
j'ai jamais fait d'erreur jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je ne fais pas
pour donc là vous êtes plutôt avec des
déchets avec tout le monde
ce moment qu on aide c'est d'être
population non non non non je vous
assure j'ai toujours raisonner comme ça
dans la vie
je me suis sacrifié pour aider les
autres parce que contrairement à
d'autres moi j'ai un métier ce que je
viens faire en utilisant mon propre
argent je redis c'est aider les gens à
avancer jusqu'à aujourd'hui et même pour
par la suite je vais toujours être là
pour aider ces gens qui ont besoin d'un
élu qui aime sa population vous disiez
être en accord avec la façon dont
emmanuel macron avance ou ou gouvernent
est ce que vous pensez qui comme lui
qu'il faut réduire la dépense publique y
compris à la réunion moi je pense que
oui autant il faut faire des efforts
dans les dépenses publiques je suis
d'accord autant il faut préserver la
situation de la réunion par rapport au
contexte spécial de notre île très
éloignées il n'y a pas de matière
première
le taux de chômage important de plus en
plus de jeunes qui sont sur le marché du
travail ou donc je pense que en
parallèle à ça il faut que nous en tout
cas on se fasse encore plus en forme au
niveau 2
du national pour que de l'assemblée
nationale aussi pour que même la
ministre mr donc qu'elles prennent plus
en considération sur le on va dire la
politique au sens économique et au sens
large du terme vous êtes pour une
politique de réduction de la dépense
publique une politique finalement assez
libérale telle que la mène emmanuel
macron actuellement même si vous
considérez qu'il faut à la réunion des
aménagements moi je pense oui il va se
dire que si vraiment c'est plutôt
d'accord avec sanary on est français
avant tout donc automatiquement quand il
fait une politique
vous savez que hollande on a un essai du
temps il a rien fait d'accord
aujourd'hui il est qu'au début
donc je pense que en parallèle à ce qui
fait qu'ils graal en parallèle je pense
que nous députés de la réunion on doit
se battre pour protéger par rapport au
contexte spécial la réunion donc qu'ils
doivent faire ci doit faire des actions
on verra le résultat dans les années qui
viennent
je veux dire on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui par voilà c'est pas bon
c'est à ça parce que nous on se préserve
quelque part regarder quand on a eu
cette possible j'ai eu cette possibilité
d'être devant lui il est quand même
revenu sur sept en fait ils pourront
venu on n'a même pas parlé de ça avec
lui c'est prévoir et on va refaire les
politiques dans un instant mais comme
intermède musical vous avez choisi nadia
ramassamy mille colombes de mireille
mathieu chanson sortie en 1977
l'écho d'un extrait pain noir parle
[Musique]
oh
les bains
et là
[Musique]
sur les toits
non
le ciel
mais
j'entends
or
[Musique]
raison
i
non
on
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
non
demain
[Musique]
et demain
[Applaudissements]
plus de 2
me
un lien
les cas
[Musique]
et je vois
ou longues
mireille mathieu qu'on va écouter en
entier sa chanson mille colombes choisi
par un autre invité nadia ramassamy en
un mot pourquoi ce choix aux filiales
api on veut faire il faut faire la paix
dans le monde il faut tout faire pour
que entente entre nous voilà madame il
ya une question composition à tournon
invités elle lui combien est-ce que vous
gagnez combien je gagne en tant que
député en général en fait moi je suis
bon avant tout médecin
donc quand vous faites je suis répond
ben je gagne mon surnom comme on dit ça
ma soeur sur mon front depuis que je
suis député j'ai perdu la moitié de mon
de mon revenu en tant que médecin donc
le métier le métier le mandat de député
me fait perdre beaucoup
globalement vous donnez combien par mois
au niveau 2 en jeu en tout ben il faut
calculer donc je veux dire moi entend
tenir sa barbe en avait je peux vous
bien peu par rapport à ce que vous avez
déclaré à la haute autorité sur la
transparence
on était entre entre 25 et 30 mille
euros par mois faire vos preuves c'est
pas 25 et quand on a dit ça ils ont
calculé par rapport au moment où je ne
gagnais j'étais pas encore député attend
donc depuis que j'ai survolé 2016 sur le
revenu 2016 donc en fait ça veut dire
que c'est déjà pas la réalité
ensuite pour donc en fait vous diminuez
à peu près de moitié
et pour moi ça n'a pas d'importance du
moment que je moi je raisonne toujours
comme ça si on m'a donné un peu plus
c'est pour utiliser le plus que j'ai
pour l'intérêt général des gens donc en
fait pour moi c'est un dévouement
le fait de perdre la moitié de mon
revenu ben c'est une façon à moi d'aider
sur la terre d'autres personnes qui en
ont besoin
voilà vous avez été vous êtes vous
l'avez dit médecin vous avez été vice
présidente du département vice
présidente du conseil régional les
députés en même temps ces derniers temps
ces derniers mois est ce que c'est un
tel cumul d'actifs à compter les répéter
votre question j'ai vachement de la
pause et donc l'accord mais répéter
quand même tous les marins vice
président du département vice-présidente
de la région jusqu'au plat ensuite après
il ya le rêve et vous avez été député
mais vous vous avez conservé pendant le
temps du recours contre votre élection
vous avez conservé tous ses mandats
pendant quelques mois de juin jusque
jusqu'à ces derniers mois ces dernières
semaines est ce que en cumulant autant
d'activités je parle pas de revenus mais
en termes d'activité j'ai mis mon nom
décrédibiliser pas est-ce que vous
contribuez pas à décrédibiliser la
fonction politique
on sait qu'il ya de moins en moins de
gens qui votent de plus en plus
d'enfants très critique des
fonctionnaires est ce qu'on peut bien
est-ce qu'on peut raisonnablement être
médecin responsable d'un secteur aux
départements et les régions est député
on répète quand on a dit que j'étais
tout ça à la fois il faut pas oublier
que en tant que conseillère
départementale et conseillère générale
de régionales je n'ai pas été rémunéré
dans le penchant de rémunération de
fonction mais parce que vous avez mon
métier ses médecins
quand on est médecin on soigne les gens
et on se rend compte au delà de soigner
ces gens ont d'autres problèmes plus
graves qu'ils répercutent sur leur santé
je me suis dit quand les gens arrivent
devant moi j'aime les aider pour qu'ils
soient heureux donc qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait comme il ya quand même des élus qui
ne sont pas compétents kong ont tout à
qui profites un système a fallu que je
me suis je me suis dit je ne donne pas
de noms je me dis simplement que il faut
faire quelque chose pour eux donc je me
suis dit les médecins ils font des
études pour être médecin donc
automatique y sont ils sont tous
compétents mais la politique on ne fait
pas des études pour être un politicien
donc il faut aller aider ces gens mais
de façon noble de façon intègre de façon
honnête donc je me suis dit en faisant
je me suis dit je me présente et à la
surprise de tout le monde
j'ai été élu très rapidement dans une
île communiste ou peu depuis vingt ans
personne n'avait syrie et bien construit
la départementale quand je suis revenu
conséquent je suis devenu pas une bonne
politique par rapport aux personnes qui
ont voulu de moi
attendez j'ai fait des études j'ai fait
j'ai fait une question c'est est ce
qu'on peut revoir parce que je continue
j'ai fait pour avoir tous les outils
nécessaires pour faire quelque chose de
bien si on m'a donné cette capacité
d'accor regardez jusqu'à aujourd'hui où
partout où je vais je fais du positif ce
qui veut dire que en moi il ya tout ce
qu'il faut pour aller au devant et pour
aider ces gens donc moi je ne vois pas
l'accumulation de travail je vois il
faut absolument aider ces gens donc par
tous les moyens donc quelque part c'est
c'est maintenant c'est mon tempérament
grâce beaucoup à ce que
ma mes parents m'ont inculqué depuis ma
jeunesse quand on veut faire quelque
chose de bien et qu'on reste honnête on
arrive toujours au but donc moi je veux
aider tant que je peux des gens qui sont
en difficulté même si marc foutu et
l'arrêt jeu par des personnes de temps
en temps j'ai à dire je passe au delà
parce que j'ai cette volonté de les
aider et on arrive toujours quand on
fait quelque chose de bien on arrive
toujours malgré tout ce cumul de ces
c'est une façon l'addition de fonctions
peu importe comment la fin j'y suis
arrivé à faire du bien de dire où il est
là quand même
la question c'est par exemple la
difficulté à être présente à l'assemblée
nationale de magna je suis regardé je
vais tous les quinze jours vous savez en
tant qu'être humain prendre l'avion tous
les quinze jours
ce n'est pas évident je le fait d'être
court et la réunion c'est notre à
paris un rassemblement ce n'est pas tout
ce qu'on attendait alors attendez pas
tous vont tous les quinze jours moi je
pars justement je suis capable de le
faire et en même temps de continuer mon
métier de présence à l'assemblée vous
faites partie des 150 personnes est
moins présente
vous avez regardé par rapport aux
réunionnais député voilà non mais elle
doivent parler en général par rapport
aux députés français oui mais regardez
par rapport aux députés de la ligue
parce que est-ce que dans la façon il
faut comparer ce qui paraît ce qu'ils
ont est ce que dans les attentes des
français aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de discussions sur ce qu'est la
politique est ce que devraient être les
évolutions démocratiques
est ce que est ce que est ce que on
considère pas aujourd'hui qu'être député
de la france c'est pas être à paris et
faire ce travail de député c'est comme
ça en tout cas qui m'a dit le maquereau
la demande et messieurs si on ne voit
pas ce qui se passe dans le quotidien
des gens
vous pensez qu'on est capable d'aller se
battre pour eux donc mon métier restera
mon métier parce que c'est là que j'ai
vu ce qui se passait dans le quotidien
et que on leur donne pas la parole pour
aller raconter ce qui se passe à la télé
de ski de dents dans leur vie de tous
les jours dont je veux dire que pour moi
c'est très complémentaire
je suis très assidus au travail
regardez en quelques mois c'est le
président la république qui m'a invité
moi pourquoi moi parce que sûrement il
ya quand même une analyse de ce que vous
avez fait pendant tout ce temps votre
parcours et on voit que vous êtes quand
même
ap et compétent à faire ce que vous
faites mais j'étais aussi la pêche
en train de continuer à me battre dans
ce sens pour aider ces familles réunies
l'état important dans les travaux des
parlementaires
bientôt ça va être le débat sur la
révision constitutionnelle évoluer le
statut la réunion vous avez depuis le
départ quand il ya eu le débat au niveau
quand on était dans nos nez qui ont
débuté et législatives
on m'a posé on parlait de ça moi je dis
que l'amendement de virapoullé a permis
de nous protéger contre tous et vous
savez tous ces gens qui disent qu'ils
veulent l'indépendance l'autonomie
l'assemblée unique et ben jeudi en
mettant dans un alinéa à la réunion il
ya un département une région ça veut
dire qu'à aucun moment quel que soit le
président qui sera à la région et au
département
si demain un des deux veut aller
détruire la réunion ben non on pourra
pas parce que votre procès sont l'unique
je suis content à 100 mais unique et je
suis pour nous sommes en garder notre
protection vis-à-vis de la france parce
qu'il faut pas oublier tout en étant
tout en étant en ayant cet alinéa on a
pu se développer
on a quand même une croissance plus
important qu'en métropole si le taux de
chômage est identique c'est uniquement
parce que nous on a une démographie de
plus en plus important il devient fou la
suppression de l'homme au niveau protégé
les réunionnaises et réunionnais contre
les mouvements autonomistes et ceux qui
véhiculent ce mouvement aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt la droite qui parle
d'autonomie qui demandent à avoir des
dérogations pour avoir une fiscalité
bien différente avec cet alinéa on le
faisait déjà parce que quand on a fait d
abattement de 30 % à la réunion gdir on
était dans cet alinéa c'est pas ça qui
nous a au contraire on a eu cet avantage
se turent jambes d'autonomie bah en fait
commencé non c'est ce que le
gouvernement a accepté pour nous et
quand vous parler d'autonomie
regardez ce qui se passe dans les pays
qui ont eu justement s'est taillé un qui
permet de faire entrer mais des lois
pays
vous savez ce que les réunionnaises et
réunionnais doivent savoir c'est que
quand on fait ses lois pays qui
trinquent
ce sont les réunionnaises et réunionnais
parce que l'état ne donne pas de
l'argent demain on dit on va diminuer
parce qu'on fait une oie pays on diminue
des impôts mais c'est pas la france qui
va donner le sur plus c'est ce qu'ils
ont décidé qu'ils vont être augmenté les
impôts locaux pour que les réunionnaises
réunionnais en pâtissent dont je dis non
il faut bien faire comprendre le
réunionnais il faut ne pas les faire
miroiter dans quelque chose qui est
irréelle qui est qui qui m'ont changé
quoi moi je suis pas d'accord verbal ou
est ce que vous serez en 2020 pour les
élections municipales en 2021 pour les
prochaines élections régionales
je pense que pour l'instant je suis
député de la réunion
j'ai un combat à mener pour ces
personnes qui ont voté pour moi et je
pense que mon travail pour l'instant
c'est de trouver des solutions pour
qu'on puisse les aider au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale c'est plus
important pour moi vous avez créé un
mouvement politique
il n'y a pas forcément c'est uniquement
les jours ont voté pour moi non en fait
le mouvement représente les personnes
qui ont voté pour moi parce que il ya
sur les vies possibles de ce mouvement
bah ça veut dire que les gens qui ont
voté pour moi c'est les gens qui ont
pris conscience qu'ils étaient nadia
ramassamy nqi et nadia ramassamy
en fait je suis un simple être humain
comme comme tout le monde et je viens
juste me dévouer pour l'intérêt des
autres c'est tout ce que j'ai à faire
donc pour moi c'est assez ça représente
tous ces gens qui ont eu confiance en
moi et qui croient en moi c'est pas un
mouvement qui pourrait soutenir d'autres
candidats ignorent que nadia ramassamy
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit simplement que
ce qui est important c'est que ben ce
mouvement bien où je serai c'est ce
qu'ils ont eu confiance en moi vous me
suivre c'est évident et je remercie
d'ailleurs la confiance que ces gens
portent à mon égard en 2020 ou est ce
que vous serez genevois disent que quand
je garde quelques ports et si la
municipalité prenne quelqu'un laissons
le temps au temps et aujourd'hui je suis
député de la réunion
donc je vais me battre pour essayer de
trouver des solutions pour que autant au
niveau de président de l'inter aux
parlementaires trouver des solutions
pour que nous soyons mieux regarder
écueil est quand même des répercussions
positives sur leur système et pour les
élections régionales les dernières
élections régionales didier robert à
compter sur vous et sur vos voix ce qui
pourra de nouveau compter sur vous vos
voix lors des prochaines régionales
pour l'instant je travaille dans
l'intérêt des réunionnaises et
réunionnais on verra par la suite ce qui
va se passer donc pour l'instant je
reste à mon mandat de député et je
continue à aider autant en parallèle
je suis à la région où je vais continuer
à aider la réunion par rapport à mon
poste autant au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale je vais le faire merci nadia
ramassamy d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
dans deux minutes les infos et ensuite
sept